let's just call it the reveal Katy Perry
isn't staying tight-lipped about her
pregnancy and she revealed a pretty big
detail while performing in Australia on
Sunday you heard it the teenage dream
singer shared that she hopes her child
with fiance Orlando Bloom is a girl and
Katie's pregnancy has already seen its
share of dramatic reveals the 35 year
old popstar first announced her news to
the world on Wednesday night when she
let her music video never worn white do
all the talking
[Music]
and on Sunday's episode of American Idol
it was all baby talk guys I can't tell
you how excited I am that we're going to
have a fourth judge on the show this
year I think it's the perfect addition
to this panel and no one was more
excited than Lionel Richie and Luke
Bryan
well should we tell would is from Katie
and Luke even came to her rescue
during a well splinter emergency I got a
splinter
[Music]
[Music]
the ordeal inspired Katie to say this
about her pregnancy kids he was on set
for Sunday's episode where she opened up
about her fur baby actually nugget we're
at a beautiful facility here at art
museum and nugget was downstairs and I
could hear her barking she actually has
she's a terrible yapper because she's so
tiny and she hasn't she feels like she
has nothing to protect her besides her
size the bark besides her bark and she's
become becoming worse with time but
rooms with bigger dogs yes my dog is a
lab in fearless with my dog
you know we always have dogs featured in
the show sometimes laughs well actually
the first season wasn't there a dog that
was just defecating you know we do get
like really bizarre moments and they're
they're not scripted no and they steal
the show and they stay in the show and
that's what makes American Idol
[Music]